hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play from dust yes I forgot what
part it was but we're gonna ignore that
cuz it don't matter it don't matter all
you need to know is that I'm gonna kick
ass I'm gonna be awesome
and you guys are gonna enjoy it well I
guess I can't make you enjoy it but
you're gonna enjoy it no matter what
alright we are about to get my infinite
earth oh but these guys are a bunch of
losers seriously what is going on guys
well I know that I destroyed you by
lighting you on fire just as you were
building it so I guess I can take the
blame for that one but I'm still gonna
blame you for all the other mistakes
what mistakes you say well I guess those
remind - oh no that's bad that's bad
yeah alright
um I don't know what to do about that
that's just gonna be the way it is let
it be let it be alright
um it stopped creating sand and all
that's left now is just lava so I really
need that infinite earth this is
something under here
alright that's something
Speirs splat no God okay can I get it
okay do your thing and bang your drums
good job good job guys
yep go go go go go oh hello
you're doing that thing okay finally got
repel Watterson now oh thank goodness
infinite earth amplify breath okay combo
boom
finally I need just land everywhere
because way too much oh sorry sorry guys
sorry to deal with it oh that's that's
okay that's my bad
that's my bad I wasn't paying attention
where I was going all yours Yosh ah why
do I destroy everything I touch okay
anyway alright moving on moving on
almost done almost done the portal
probably revealed itself and then went
away because I was an idiot always there
it is okay I still don't know what this
is all about this stream but doesn't
seem to want to be stopped up
well look at that it's forming river
deltas that's how it does it
that's really cool okay almost got that
village back yeah sorry about that
sorry sorry about that okay all right
almost now banging banging on your drum
II drums I really need to stop just
completely destroying my villages
because that's just bad juju all right
and the portal has opened there's a
problem here okay now I have infinite
amplify okay I'm just gonna start
filling in not tidal waving everyone I
care about
okay Go Go Go Go man go all right make
it progress
finally finally making progress
all right that sounds good this town is
now good there's someone coming here
that's that's fire got your fire oh good
you finally took God no you don't I know
you don't after I get out of here look
hello doobie Doo go lady go use your
cane new story all right I will I will
at once I'm done with this I will go
I can let you all read what the stories
are about
I think I can get out of here now I mean
technically I could wait for 100% of
vegetation again but um the benefits of
that aren't as good as keeping the story
going so I will send guys here and gals
go go go what's the dealio
oh that's the Leo okay one second need
infinite ah okay this needs to stop
going that way
build it up building up building up go
the other way smartass oh that's good
this tidal waves at least do my best
can't promise anything you know it is me
we're talking about here and I am a
renowned [ __ ] when it comes to these
things ah I know no no no go go Oh go
faster
Oh jellify a hole yeah man that has a
tall wave that would uh that would have
demolished them you you are so lucky I'm
here
Wow look at that look at that what
happens if I dub earth on it it gets
higher yeah oh look at it go yeah get up
on it get up on it look at that yeah oh
is that scary from your height I don't
know hang on let me check
let's see yeah that would be pretty damn
terrifying good thing you're leaving
this place all right get out of here
there we go
once again very pretty even from ground
level you kind of missed them out there
but I won't judge it for that
okay where am I now bring it on
Oh bring it on what we got here looks
normal to me
movements the ground gonna start moving
on me Minelli yeah be my salah DCPI
yakeen ICICI uh-huh
bring it Wow I see many jackoff
[ __ ]
uh-huh all right looks like I got more
people this time training off and on
volcanoes seems active okay that's
probably bad so let's send people here
oh I need build one village um what gave
me more people so I guess I can bum-rush
these please now jellify water not that
one not jellified um separate maybe
that'd be more useful maybe maybe not
yeah people go in here I guess I got to
go one at a time of course of course
okay
well it's like a bowl so I'm wondering
if this bowl is gonna fill up with stuff
maybe I can blow up Oh scheisse that
better be it because I'm gonna blow up a
whole
I can't see anything
boom as if this bull does fill up with
water I'm gonna want to drain it oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy
Brandin beware of floods oh boy oh boy
oh no oh no this looks bad
boom okay help me Ike oh oh no oh no oh
no oh no come on what it's completely
flooded now give me give me
oh come on what is that all about
get all the way guys dumping lava hot
stuff
Oh get out of there get out of there get
away run away - you burn up it's not my
fault I gave you a chance all right
there you go oh I'm sorry I couldn't do
anything about that okay yeah I got you
I'm gonna try to
great some something to carve a path out
of here okay
that kind of worked okay I got amplified
breath don't know what I can do with
that I'm just gonna blow these things up
and hope for the best
I got any more no no ah here we go
lots of it all right boink
I'm sorry ah [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
okay that's working it's working it's
working oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I should get up
man that village man uh I don't even
know if I'm gonna make it these guys get
out of here dirt how many times do I
have to tell you I don't want you dirt
okay
oh [ __ ] I can't quite get there I want
to get there but uh I saw it probably
intentionally made it so that I couldn't
reach past the ridge no way can't get it
a [ __ ] okay that that plans not gonna
work oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] how am I
gonna win this I can't I can't there's
no way to win this is there oh oh man oh
they're all dying they're all doing
either they're dead they're dead they're
dead
oh [ __ ] how do i how I don't know I do
not know this is a puzzle this puzzling
puzzling puzzle oh boy
oh you guys are screwed guys are so
screwed maybe I could try to build
something boom Oh
you barely built the town and you're
already in trouble that's bad news
Oh oh boy it's gonna flood again and
then it's just gonna just gonna make the
water level rise and there's nothing I
can do about it what am I gonna do what
am i what am what am I gonna do what am
I gonna do I don't know all right I need
to think about this so I'm gonna cut it
here and thank you guys so much for
watching I always appreciate it and
stick around because the next part will
be coming shortly I don't remember what
part it was but it's coming it'll be the
next one thank you bye bye